all i know is is that i am
i'm i'm
totally unmodified uh-huh and
that's all i can i can share and and and
i think i think tom tom is very good at
marketing yes yeah
andrew garfield addresses tom holland's
fake butt claims in the spidey suit tom
holland did recently say that one of you
guys wore a fake butt on set so i need
to know i heard this
let's rewind
back in february andrew's spider-man no
way home co-star revealed that at least
one of his predecessors who made
surprise cameos in the latest
installment may have sported a little
extra cushion in their spidey suit but
the question remains who was it andrew
or toby maguire i'm not gonna tell you
who but one of us has a fake ass in
their suit really
wow
you can figure out that for yourself
well yeah the 25 year old actor wouldn't
say and on thursday andrew addressed
tom's claim on late night with seth
meyers he's just stirring the pot old
tom he can't help himself you know
there's an expression that we have in
entertainment which is we want to put
bums on seats yeah you know we want to
we want to get the audience sat and get
paying paying their tickets
yeah according to the 38 year old tick
tick boom star his co-star knows how to
grab the audience's attention
tom is pretty great at uh creating
sub genres of games for you all while
while you're in the cinema go well that
butt doesn't look real toby's looks like
it might be real yeah could andrew have
that much ass i maybe
potentially and andrew he cleared up the
cheeky assumptions i am totally
unmodified
and that echoes what the oscar nominee
told et back in february who had the
fake butt andrew well i have no idea
it's not not me so i have no clue i
don't want to like i don't want to i
don't know i assumed everyone's butts
were their butts so it's not you it's
not tom so i guess no i don't think it's
totally i've seen toby's butt toby's
toby's got back
hmm so could it be tom i am sweating
well we may never know
it's uh exposing it's revealing as hell
but like you know what can you do about
that as for andrew he's now out of
spidey mode and on to promoting his
latest project under the banner of
heaven what if tonight is just the first
edge of a bone
finally working its way out my producer
is convinced like you play this guy he's
such a good guy and we see him being a
father an incredible husband and
she thinks that fans are going to have a
real crush on this detective so are you
ready for that
it's like a like a dilf
like a dill yeah detective they'd like
to and dad it works a detective they'd
like to
[Laughter]
yeah i mean
listen i'm just trying to i'm just
trying to give give the people what they
want
[Music]